لمصممه جرافيكس مصريه عالميه سبق
واختارتها فوربس ضمن قائمه تضم اهم 30
فنان تحت سن الثلاثين في 2017 وجمعيه الفن
المطبعي في شيكاغو اختارتها من افضل مئه
مصمم جرافيك في العالم ولها اعمال عن عرضت
حول العالم مشاركه في مسابقات عالميه كمان
ومعروفه محليه جدا كمان غاده معها ماجستير
في التصميم ومعروفه باعمالها لكن من فتره
سمعنا باسمها وسط ازمه اتهامات سرقه من
فنان روسي واليوم نفس الفنان اتهمها من
جديد وبخصوص اعمال ثانيا فاللي صاير انه
فنان روسي اسمه جورجي كورسوف طلع واتهم
غاده بان سرقت تصميمات لو الكلام طلع على
لسان محامي الفنان وبيقول المحامي انه
الفنان كورسوف اكتشف انه احد لوحاته
ورسوماته استخدمت في اعلان
صممته غاده وقال انه ماشي في اجراءات
مقاضات الشركه وغاده وانه كمان بيطالب
باعتذار وتع المادي ضخم لكن لازم نقول هنا
ان المحامي والفنان ما طلعوا مستندات ولا
صور ولا ادله يعني ما طلعوا شيء يثبت
كلامهم وقالوا بس انهم راح يقدموا هذه
الادله اللي عندهم هي للقضاء الموضوع ملفت
لانه نفس هذا الفنان من شهور اتهم غاضب
انها سرقت لوحات من اعماله في تصاميم
جداريات على محطه مترو كليه البنات في
القاهره ووقت الموضوع كبير جدا وانتهى
الموضوع باعتذار الهيئه القوميه للانفاق
من الفنان والجمهور وازاله الجداريه نرجع
للازمه اللي صايره الان الاعلان اللي
بيتكلم عنه الفنان الروسي هي التصاميم
اللي شايفينها امامكم لهذه الكنز احنا
تواصلنا مع غاده اللي بتنفي طبعا كل كلام
الفنان الروسي وبتاكد انه هي كمان راح
تلجا للقضاء المصري وبتثق فيه عدالته غاده
زودتنا بالصور اللي شايفينها امامكم الان
واللي قالت انها من الاسكتشات الخاصه فيها
للتصاميم اللي كانت على العلم
غاده كمان خصتنا بفيديو حصري من كمبيوتر
الشخصي بيثبت تصميمها بنفسها للحمله
الاعلانيه
وغير الصور والفيديو اللي شفناه غاده
ولحبت من خلال تفاعلكم ترد بالصوت والصوره
ولاول مره على الاتهامات الموجهه لها
مساء الخير دي اول مره اطلع اتكلم فيها في
حياتي انا السنه اللي فاتت اتعرضت الازمه
كبيره جدا اعلاميه
وساعتها انا كنت بولد وحصري مشاكل في
الولاده وكنت في المستشفى في مكانش عندي
فرصه ارد بكل قوتي بس المره دي انا هرد
انا زي اي حد اي بني ادم اتعرض لتنمر
الكتروني بالشكل الكبير جدا ده تاثر نفسيا
ومهنيا لمده السنه اللي فاتت دي كلها وده
بيحصل لي تاني دلوقتي فده بالنسبه لي
كابوس همم مش قادره اشوفه تاني بيحصل من
غير ما اعرف اتكلم وادافع عن نفسي ادم من
ساعه ما رجعت من ايطاليا بعد ما خلصت
الماجستير بتاعي
كل هدفي في الحياه انني ازاي اخلي التصميم
يحيي التراث المصري فده مش اول مشروع
اعمله بيتكلم عن نفس الفكره دي ولا ثاني
ولا ثالث ولا رابع مش اي حد ممكن يقول اي
اتهام نصدقه من غير ما يكون في اي دلائل
الحمله بتاعه شركه المياه الغازيه دي
اتعملت في سنه 2018 وانا رسمت الرسومات دي
بايديا موجوده على النت ممكن تشوفوها
ودي كان اول مره الشركه دي تقتبس من فنان
مصري ما تاخدش مثلا التصميم من الاوفيس
بتاعهم في نيويورك او في بتاعتهم ومن كتر
ما الحمله دي كانت ناجحه الشركه طلبت مني
اني اعمل مسابقه في كليه فنون تطبيقيه مع
الطلاب
بنفس الفكره ان ازاي اختاروا تصميم ويحيا
وتصميم مصري هم بيحبوه وده احلى حاجه
شفتها في حياتي لان فعلا الهدفي كان
بيتحقق التراب كانت مبسوطه قوي حسوا
بانتماء
لتاريخنا وتصممنا الملهمه الجميله اللي مش
محتاجين نقلد حاجه او نوصل لحاجه بره عشان
نحس بها
انا طبعا بحترم كل الفنانين جوه او بره
مصر
وبحترم القانون المصري والقضاء المصري
لانه قضاء عادل فانا عشان كده هالجا
القضاء ده واي حد عنده مشكله ثانيه ممكن
يلجا للقضاء المصري برضه لان انا تعبت جدا
في ال 15 سنه من جريدي اني شركتي تعبت جدا
في فريق عملي ااا وتعبت برده عشان اوصل
لصقه عميري للداني مشروع كبير ومهم زي ده
انا مش هسيب حقي وبحترم شغلي اللي فات
واللي جاي شكرا
[موسيقى]